vous allez le voir demain dans les
données
les impacts du télétravail
sont énormes on voit qu'il y a des
changements importants des habitudes
entre autres aux heures de pointe
François Hugo a justifié l'abandon de sa
promesse de construire un troisième lien
authenti entre Québec et les vies par
l'impact du télétravail la ministre des
Transports a parlé d'une décision
difficile mais responsable et
pragmatique Geneviève Guilbaud
présentera demain la nouvelle version du
projet qui sera réservé aux transports
en commun qu'en est-il exactement du
télétravail trois ans après le début de
la pandémie et le télétravail est-il là
pour rester avec nous ce soir Diane
Gabriel Tremblay professeur à l'École
des sciences de l'administration de
l'Université
alors le nom quand on regarde le nombre
de voitures qui circulent sur le Pont
Pierre Laporte le nombre de voitures qui
circulent et là c'est un gros graphique
qui monte clairement que dans les depuis
le début de la pandémie il y a eu une
chute du nombre de véhicules qui
utilisent le Pont Pierre Laporte on est
revenu pratiquement 30 ans en arrière au
niveau de la circulation est-ce que
c'est l'effet télétravail
ben je dirais que oui c'est clairement
l'effet du télétravail les gens se
déplacent moins je suis pas une experte
en circulation automobile les gens
continuent de se déplacer pour autre
chose mais par contre pour la région de
Québec sans doute qu'ils vont moins au
centre-ville comme c'est le cas
d'ailleurs pour Montréal dans peu près
tout les centres-villes au fond on
constate qu'il y a moins de déplacements
liés au travail et donc surtout moins à
des moments où on est obligé genre aux
arbres de pointe le matin et le soir ça
c'est clairement quelque chose qui
diminue et donc quand le gouvernement
associe les changements
d'habitudes de déplacement au
télétravail pour vous c'est une raison
c'est raisonnable de dire ça en rapport
avec l'annonce du gouvernement
j'aurais tendance à penser que oui parce
que si on regarde les chiffres sur le
télétravail tout au long de la pandémie
on a vu les gens aimaient faire du
télétravail même si ça n'était pas
toujours facile dans ce contexte là et
moi je travaille sur cette question là
depuis 20 ans et puis on voit bien que
les gens ils voyaient les avantages il y
avait une demande d'attente si on peut
dire pour le télétravail et après 2 ans
3 ans d'expérimentation après avoir au
fond démontré que c'est tout à fait
possible de le faire mais effectivement
les gens souhaitent faire du travail et
beaucoup d'employeurs l'accepte en ce
moment avec la rareté de main d'oeuvre
aussi c'est un facteur d'attraction très
important mais là je pense que oui les
employeurs mais là on est on prend la
décision maintenant trois ans après le
début de la pandémie avec des
statistiques sur les déplacements sur
les ponts puis les statistiques sur les
télétravail faut se projeter bien sûr
dans le temps
dans cinq ans dans 10 ans dans 15 ans ce
que vous constatez en fonction de votre
expertise madame Tremblay est-ce que ce
que le télétravail est devenu vraiment
une tendance qui va durer dans le temps
je pense que si on regarde les chiffres
qui nous indiquent que la très grande
majorité aime le télétravail pour toutes
sortes de raisons essentiellement
justement parce que ça réduit les
déplacements il y a quand même 70% des
personnes qui veulent faire plus de 50%
de leur temps en télétravail même un 10%
qui veulent faire tout leur temps en
télétravail donc clairement la tendance
est là il y a à peine 10% de personnes
selon cette Canada qui disent qu'elles
veulent travailler à plein temps au
bureau donc la tendance est claire et
déjà on peut dire comme je vous le
disais il y avait une demande latente en
fait beaucoup de gens souhaitaient le
faire mais leur employeur leur disait
que ça n'était pas possible alors là
maintenant on a montré que c'était
possible et donc de toute évidence la
demande du côté des employés elle est là
et est-ce que davantage le secteur
propice au télétravail dans la région de
Québec
clairement en fait la région de Québec
si on regarde les secteurs globalement
ou c'est propice et là Québec est encore
plus disons avantagé sur ce plan là les
administrations publiques ont fait plus
de télétravail que dans d'autres
secteurs le secteur finance et assurance
est très clairement dans la région
Québec il y a quand même un bon nombre
de siège sociaux d'entreprises
d'assurance il y a aussi un grand nombre
d'employés je crois que c'est à peu près
17000 quelque chose comme ça technologie
de l'information aussi on fait beaucoup
de télétravail 19 000 employés mais
l'administration publique à elle seule
600 69 000 employés c'est beaucoup de
monde donc on a vraiment comme les
secteurs majoritaires c'est vrai qu'il y
a d'autres secteurs où on en fait moins
l'hôtellerie la restauration et tout
mais quand même la santé l'éducation
manufacturier bien sûr mais Québec n'est
pas une économie de manufacturier est-ce
que les gens aiment le télétravail en
raison surtout des pertes de temps qu'on
peut avoir dans le trafic
oui donc c'est la raison majeure très
clairement mais en même temps les gens
vont nous dire ça me permet aussi une
meilleure différenciation entre ma vie
personnelle professionnelle on sait très
bien que il y a des gens qui doivent
aller chercher les enfants à la garderie
les amener les ramener pour ces
situations là c'est beaucoup plus
avantageux beaucoup de gens vont dire
aussi je peux mieux concentrer on sait
que dans les entreprises il y a beaucoup
d'arts ouvertes maintenant ça n'est pas
pour tout le monde c'est pas toujours
facile de se concentrer sur son travail
de faire un travail de qualité de
rédaction par exemple donc tout dépend
du type de travail qu'on fait mais
beaucoup de gens vont aussi dire moi
j'aime bien parce que je peux me
concentrer davantage et le midi je peux
peut-être aller faire du vélo ou faire
du sport ce que j'aurais pas pu faire en
étant au centre-ville peut-être
qu'est-ce qui ferait que les gens
reviennent en présentiel vraiment
voudraient le faire j'imagine un
troisième lien formidable et très utile
et très rapide
honnêtement je suis pas convaincue dans
ce sens où il y a tellement d'avantages
les gens le disent les chiffres sont
vraiment et depuis le début de la
pandémie et jusqu'à aujourd'hui et moi
je peux vous dire comme j'ai travaillé
là-dessus avant donc même en temps dit
normal entre guillemets on voyait déjà
c'est très très forte demande ou
préférence pour le télétravail donc je
pense c'est assez difficile de ramener
les gens et de s'imaginer que tout va
changer peut-être que bien sûr ils vont
revenir au centre-ville de Québec pour
aller au restaurant et d'autres choses
mais pour le travail je pense que on
préfère clairement leur rester à
domicile dernière question grève des
fonctionnaires fédéraux parmi les points
qui achoppent c'est la demande des
syndicats dans chasser le télétravail
dans les conventions collectives quoi
c'est quoi de cette idée là
ben je pense qu'il faut en discuter
quand on était à 8 % de télétravail
occasionnels d'ailleurs la fonction
publique avait une annexe qui datait
assez longtemps et dans la plupart des
milieux de travail ça n'était pas
réglementé il y avait pas de règle
précise là-dessus c'était un peu
occasionnel avec le supérieur immédiat
qui décidait si on regarde du côté de
l'Europe pourtant le télétravail n'est
pas toujours aussi développé la
France au plus réglementée il y a une
directive européenne sur le télétravail
il y a des accords de branches en France
et des accords d'entreprise et les
accords d'entreprise se multiplient en
ce moment en France donc je pense que
c'est très clair qu'il faut
réglementer alors est-ce qu'il faut
absolument que ce soit dans la
convention collective dans une annexe
une réglementation mais moi je pense que
quand il y a 30% de gens qui font du
télétravail je comprends qu'il faille en
discuter et qui a des règles le nombre
de jours qui décident un peu tout ça
Diane Gabriel Tremblay toujours
intéressant votre analyse merci
ça m'a fait plaisir bonne fin de journée
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI